wer entscheidet das weltweite rennen
rund um den hyper lobt die ihre
nachricht es könnte vielleicht hamburg
seien dort gibt es nämlich einen
spektakulären plan wie der heimklub dort
eingesetzt werden kann und mit dem bau
soll schon bald begonnen werden klicks
um sind windschnittig gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst ihr kein video
herzlich willkommen bei den edlen musk
chroniken das ist wirklich eine ehre
aber auch gar nicht so unrealistisch
geschichte der hyper lob soll nach
hamburg kommen um genau zu sein in den
hamburger hafen
denn die hamburger hafengesellschaft hat
etwas ganz besonderes mit dem
hochgeschwindigkeits transportmittel vor
kurz noch mal die idee hinter dem hyper
lob und die ist wirklich super einfach
rohrpost und die könnte der
magnetschwebetechnik jetzt im nachhinein
zum erfolg verhelfen das prinzip der zug
oder beim halb eine kapsel wird in eine
röhre gepackt und in der herrscht ein
vakuum bzw
es kommen noch luft enthalten ein
sogenanntes teil vakuum
hochleistungspumpen pumpen die luft aus
der röhre und erhalten das vakuum der
effekt es gibt keinen oder so gut wie
keinen luftwiderstand mehr das
hauptproblem und der energiefresser
jedes schnellen transportes der ist
einfach weg war
damit brauche ich für den zug kaum noch
energie ist er einmal beschleunigt
sollen solarzellen auf den
transporteuren ausreichen um für die
energie zu sorgen und eine neue
magnetschwebetechnik ist geplant bei der
deutlich weniger energie verbraucht wird
permanentmagneten die im sogenannten
halbach array angeordnet sind sollen zum
einen die magnetkraft in die kapsel
nahezu auf null reduzieren und im
gegenzug unten zum transport track
verstärken
in dem track heißt die technik die von
hyper lud transportation technologies
kurz hallo thees angewendet wird um
genau diese technik soll in hamburg
eingesetzt werden die hamburger hafen
und logistik ag hhla hat laut hamburger
abendblatt mit hyper loop tt eine
absichtserklärung unterzeichnet demnach
geht es um einen revolutionären plan die
lastwagen sollen nämlich raus aus dem
hamburger hafen damit auch raus aus der
city und das ist wirklich genial der
plan ist eine station am container
terminal
bisher werden die container dort per
autonomen fahren mit selbst fahrenden
transporter sogenannten automatically
zum container lager transportiert
zukünftig sollen sie dann zur hyper loop
station gefahren werden wo die hyper lob
kapseln durch computergesteuerte kräne
mit den containern beladen werden bis zu
4100 container könnten dann so täglich
mit unglaublichen 1200 kilometern pro
stunde zu einer station im hamburger
umland geschossen werden so hyper lobte
t laut hamburger abendblatt dort
übernehmen dann lkw die container damit
werden zwei fliegen mit einer klappe
geschlagen weniger verkehr und damit
eben auch weniger feinstaub in hamburgs
luft und schnellere zustellung von waren
und mit dem bau soll schon in zwei bis
drei jahren begonnen werden wow und die
idee kann man weiter spinnen denn eine
solche strecke ließen sie sich ja auch
verlängern
wie wäre es mit einer umladestation bei
berlin einer im ruhrgebiet einer bei
stuttgart münchen leipzig und so weiter
und so fort und die container würden
dann mit elektro lkw zu ihrem
bestimmungsort gebracht werden hammer
wir hätten ein total ökologisches und
dazu wahnsinnig schnelles waren
verteilsystem in deutschland wie es mit
dem hyper lob in deutschland weitergeht
erfahrt ihr hier bei klick suchen wenn
er kein video dazu verpassen dann
abonniert auch den englischen kanal auch
da gibt's videopremieren dafür hier
klicken und darunter geht es weiter mit
also da competition vor allen masc
flying cranes from china
ich freue mich auf dem englischen kanal
euch zu sehen csu stay tuned